this video is sponsored by liquid IV more on them
after the reaction [Music] people citizens of the
reject Nation it is time to get our hunger on
with a ballad of songbirds and snakes John how
are you I'm excited that's good to hear John I
think you're doing a reference I've only seen
the Hunger Games movies one time but I'm ready
to catch every Easter egg in reference baby I'm
going to do it all watch guys we're going to
nail it what do you guys think of this movie
did you like it is it good does it live up to the
previous Trilogy leave your thoughts down below
you know what to do leave a like that'd be great
also thank you to prepper for helping us set down
these highlights full length Reaction watch long
and where you sync up with your own copy of The
Hunger Games the ballot of song birds and snakes
we cannot mention this movie without mentioning
the whole title so anyway The Hunger Games the
ballot of song birds and snakes that is available
for our super sex reix at our patreon page and
over there we cover some things exclusively
with highlights and watch songs included ready
to get your game on I'm ready to watch Hunger
Games with ballot of song wordss and snakes me
too let's Hunger Games Ballad of song Words and
[Music]
snakes whoa the dark dark days 3 years prior oh
man and 10 years before the first
Purge there's some food over here
quick
who damn it's like a Warg threat
eliminated oh man the [Music] butcher
why is he doing he's starving [Music]
cannibalism come in ignorance and want
your father is dead cor elanus it was
a rebel will they say trap out in the
forest that's why he hates rebellions
and especially why he hates 12 it's up to us
now to make him proud and he was just out in
the snow yeah actually ooh finally going to
learn about my favorite dictator a child of
Fire 3 years later you got to grow up fast in
this Hunger Game streets where's the shirt you
don't need a shirt look at you yeah don't insult
us man look I did it I I did something and you
should really eat something today save them for
Grand that you looks so handsome oh it's going
to be a tragic downfall of him yeah it's going
to be real sad when she dies horribly future
president of PanAm We Salute You just she is
a real array of bright energy though about the
grades never miss class 10 years is that why he
even Dean High bottom can't deny us this now High
bottom High bottom what's the first thing you'll
spend the prize money on new dress more bleach
for the curtains chocolate chocolate something so
simple the plen prize will be able to pay the rent
snowlands on top it does it does gravitationally
speaking but do flowers grow in the snow D this
looks great yeah that's a badass [Music] statue
there's something excited about returning to the
world of The Hunger Games yeah are you sweating
it's reaping day we gave driver the morning off
that ingr should be begging to show for you around
today just don't forget I was your class partner
while you're gloating over the plinth Pride I
volunteer as tribute sorry he said driver so
that's a snazzy shirt what are those buttons Tess
that's why they remind me of the maid's bathroom
have you tried this land that's scandalous only
the Vault that he not teach a table manners maybe
he would have if he wasn't so busy running the
country hey they called us here for the plint
prize right I hate all of you guys plint and look
at his spawn who would have thought that you could
buy your way into the capital I mean of course
you can I don't like him or acne I tolerate him
his district as I do with all plees I heard one
more time how immoral these Hunger Games are I'll
put them in the arena my oh so Janus you made
it to the reaping for once and you made it to
graduation Festus we're both shocked burned Hey
listen I know you have high hopes for this but
there is no price today not anymore what is
that supposed to mean got some inite insight
Intel oh oh Viola I am Dr volumia G your humble
head game maker in charge of the war department
and all its affiliated cond con certain that is
a credential I've broken free of my laboratory to
examine you the leaders of the next generation
seems like an evil scientist cross with like
an eccentric old witch or something yeah I am
honored to introduce to you the creator of The
Hunger Games themselves here we go Dean Casa High
bottom is he a drunk does he know things I have
summoned you all here today for the 10th Annual
reaping ceremon in which we choose two children
from each district to throw into the capital Arena
to fight to the death in The Hunger Games he does
not seem proud of this and here sit our own 24
top prospects all waiting to hear the results
of hard study in this prestigious institution
eager to learn who's won that plin prize no
doubt it's all they can talk about I am here to
tell you that there has been a change this year
one final assignment to prove your worth a tri
wizard tournament the esteemed citizen of the
capital have grown bored of the games and simply
aren't watching anymore and if the games are to
continue at all there must be an audience head
game maker Dr Gul has stepped in to spice things
up the plain prize will no longer be determined
by who has the best grades who is the best Mentor
in the Hunger Game oh he's going to Mentor someone
in the Hunger Games dang as the reaping progresses
live I will allocate each district tribute a
capital Mentor behind the scenes one who must
just persuade them just to get them emotionally
involved obviously the best Mentor will be the
one whose tribute wins the games what if I get a
pathetic run girl from one of the poor districts
like8 or 12 no he's going to die in 2 minutes
like they did last year and the year before
don't be strictest Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles Miss crane victory in
the games is only one of our consideration your
entire future rests on this last project that's
how much they connect with a contestant that
anyone caught cheating to give their tributes
an unfair Advantage we'll just have no future at
all cuz you be dead that's a death threat Coro is
going to get a 12 let the reaping ceremony begin I
love Peter Dinklage man yeah he just so great boy
everywhere go to Livia cardo I got a good one how
boy goes to S Janice plen hey we got the pick of
the letter you forget I'm part of that letter so
brooding you never forget oh oh he's going to get
Rachel Z okay yeah oh that's right she right now
10 boy Deisha whims oh he's going to get 12 he's
got to he's got beef with them District 12 oh he
does belongs to corena snow look out you get the
best looking one man yeah and she could sing Lucy
gray bear wow this looks like like when you wait
in line for a ride at uh Six Flags yeah it's
one costume character and the rest of us pants
talk about the architecture sing your way out of
this one Lucy gray oh look out that girl got beef
what is that dress she's some sort of clown hey I
didn't know I didn't know I'm sorry her makeup is
on point got to be even now you have to be playing
to the people snake oh and she's the song [Music]
bird a [__] I got a troublemaker
help her help not Emma
Stone whoa
damn this movie is so woke hit
women now yeah gone that far
into woke territory I only want to see
people hitting women or B [Laughter]
[Music] oh he's gonna be
good there is a power to songs
man power of Harmony there's a
Unity some prayer singing she
out of her mind she's already doing the show man
[Music] oh the solders like let
let just don't tap your feet just
just don't Capital says keep rolling I
know dude he locked out she's going to
be a star yeah exactly oh this mic is
is here who who who who put this mic
here he's falling in love you can kiss
my ass H feisty got Moxy there's a
response what sup [__] Lucy graybeard out proud
I see like your father you knew my father he and
I were best friends BFS 4 L your makeshift shirt
and your two tight shoes trying desperately to
fit in when I know the Snows don't have a Pott to
piss in oh no wonder Dad and aren't best friends
good luck with that poor little song Lucy gray
won't survive a minute inside that Arena so that
means we have to make every second before then
count I'll get her to sing again I wouldn't sing
a note for you if I was her she's District
Tigers she knows we hate her and she wants
us dead how am I supposed to get her to trust
me manipulation imagine it was your name that
they p and you had been ripped from your home
don't discount her just because she's distra
you might have more in common with her than you
think he's going to play the G game that he's
going to end up falling in love with her yeah
he's going to go against everything he believes
in the Roses the white roses I mean she
seems like she'd be smart enough to see
through any [__] though yeah she seems
like an already well established [Music]
Rebel I'm Lucy Gray you must be
snow welcome to the capital when
I was little my mama used to bathe
me in buttermilk and rose [Music]
petals I eat your rose petals I eat it
up I'm your Mentor a rebel what does
my mentor do besides bring me roses I do
my best to take care of you no good luck
with that gorgeous hey you got spunk
excuse me can I can I borrow your gun
hey seeing the ugliness of the system you
help to [Music] perpetuate you really stand
out Ain going to eat you alive boy you in
the wrong cage no this cage is delightful
will kill you right now he'll do it too Reaper
killed a peacekeeper back in 11 I say we all
kill her I'm in yeah this is a wild idea y'all
got family back home kill them if you hurt him
besides he's my mentor I might need him
how come you get a mendor you each get
one oh no oh [Music] no protect her whoa what
the Jesus oh right in a cage oh Jesus Sportsman
oh is he young Stanley Tui he's young Stanley
Tui flickerman I'm lucious lucky flickerman a
man who needs no introduction you'll know me as
your favorite weatherman then amateur magician
hey the capital Zoo where this year's tributes
will be held here on display Behind These Bars
for your viewing pleasure oh that is sick
a human dis yeah hello sir yes you in the
red who are you and why are you in there with
them we're live be there their Mentor OH you
could use the relationship to help Elevate Own It
sing to them may I introduce you to my neighbors
response would be appreciated but anything would
be nice he's going on back there hello can they
not hear me in there sound barrier hi how do
you do oh my name is Cory Elena snow and this
is my tribute Lucy grey bar from District 12 hi
there what's your name my name is punches and
I'm from kids interview fans.com where did you
find that snake oh he found me must have been
a music lover must sing and calmed him WRA down
no one who might you be oh you don't know who I
am don't laugh not everyone has televisions out
in the districts wow this is like if the purge
succeeded yeah seriously I'm not actually from
12 know my people are cvy we're like a family
we're musicians by trade and we travel from place
to place it's the fancy takes us at least we used
to before the peacekeepers rounded us up she's
got such personality do you know my mentor his
name is Corina snow and clearly I got the cake
with the cream cuz nobody else has even bother
it to show up yeah I like you a lot she's
running the show the game makers did tell
you to jump in the cage with them they just
said that it was a mentor's job to introduce
our tributes to the citizens of panm if Lucy gray
is brave enough to be here then why shouldn't I
be too for the record I didn't have a choice yep
that's important to note so come down to the zoo
and see these tributes before it's too late and
I mean too late before they're dead I'm lucrecias
lucky flickerman that is a hell of a trick yeah
how'd you do that I mean she seems very capable
and I she kind of treats it like she's getting
exposure yeah for her music career yes she's been
planning this great way to get some followers
your little Excursion is in violation of about
five different Academy rules Mr snow you I'm
moving for the game makers to disqualify you
as Mentor immediately wow what a jerk and you
ucing her to people you make it look as if one
and the same as those animals a tributes are
human beings just like us shut up dude you're
harshing the vibe snow fell down in the cage down
in the cage but wow what is she doing everything
maybe one day you'll be a game maker like me what
are the hunger games for they're to punish the
districts for their Uprising they're for Ratings
commemorate the end of the war commemorate the
dull dull dull punishment can take Myriad forms
we need the emotion we be asking ourselves whether
or not they're right in the first place we have a
problem with my game were 2 years old when the war
ended the oldest of them were only eight you're
not going to be a good Mentor yeah the capital
is supposed to be everyone's government now it is
supposed to protect all of us now making children
fight each other to the death is protecting
anyone that sort of sympathy might interfere
with your mentoring assignment maybe s Janus is
on to something here maybe we should be viewing
those tributes as human beings what I just wanted
to get to know Lucy gray like wanting to get to
know a lion yeah doesn't mean you let him to make
the stakes personal who will watch the games if
they care what happens to the tributes everyone I
watched American Idol people need someone to root
for and someone to root against against we need
them to invest and if we bend a few Capital laws
we could even have them place bets wow you really
instrumented everything yeah a whole vision for
how this could be even better and even worse how
to create engagement with the hunger canes I'd
like you to write up a proposal of these thoughts
tonight Mr snow wait you you might you might
actually use his ideas if it'll help the ratings
why not corus and I are class Partners we do all
of our assignments to what a snake jeez dude
it'll be an interesting test I mean what's the
har they're saying The Hunger Games aren't working
so you got to try something different yeah why not
emotional investment this is the future right they
should learn their lessons from prior marketing
tips yeah but why does this experience leave him
so cold my classmate back in too it's not your
fault to I know I'm so blameless I'm choking on
it father bought him for me you know at the raping
just so he could show me that I could never go
back to T your father sounds like a yeah but being
capital is going to kill me so do something about
it eat this bread eat your bread sandwich quite
the rebel I am I'm bad news don't waste your time
the boy's bad news is that for us it's lber spread
I'm not hungry you think I can't hear your stomach
growling just a big you can't eat pred alone man
what happened to his neck bat bot oh first night
on the train he thought i' give him superpowers
man bat he didn't sleep away the whole journey
cuz he was keeping the bats off me so I get some
rest what the what one thing I learned in 12 is
that hunger is a weapon your friend over there
sure knows it that's why I keep all the host here
starving yeah I might have a chance to help you
I might even be able to get the audience to send
you gifts in the arena food and water to keep you
going microphones a recording studio you just have
to try singing again to win people over I don't
sing when I'm told I sing when I have something
to say we'll find something to say the guards
say you get money if you get more people to watch
and you say you want to help me which is it both
yes by helping you it helps him you seem like
a good man Corina snow you have no idea you're
a good man Draco Malfoy sure would have been
nice to meet you under different circumstances
one of your shows maybe yeah you could have
had a drink oh could have done it yeah knock
boots wow dude oh yeah go for it Jesus
who that was great whoa it's okay hold
on hold on look at me hold on it's okay I'll get
out this is not going to help your
whole thing with Jesus yep so she
did and the narrative will make it look like
that a Savage killed her yeah this is how we
Begins the war it was my fault I suggested we get
closer to the tribute it wasn't your fault she sh
like a [__] this was bound to happen somehow
she's not a rebel Grand she's just a girl trust
me that one hasn't been a girl in a long time wow
oh is she hunter from Euphoria I've been wondering
she looks familiar she will use you you must use
her or you'll end up dead in the trees like your
father yesh such like a soap opera whatever we
cut to anyone who's not part of the the players
in The Hunger Games yeah you're in like the most
Gody places dealing with like the most Upper Crust
issues yeah half these people probably do have
like a missing twin brother back from the dead our
president has decided that the games must go on
of course show everyone the capital is unafraid of
such acts of Terror that be given into Rebellion
later this evening there will be a special telev
presentation of each tribute to our audience to
you know get to know them have an hour to discuss
strategy I love how he just playing Tyrion again
I know just an American accent Tyrion dress like
a freaking monk you may begin I like his attitude
though it's is funny there's like a divide between
him and col and but he's probably going to end
up more like him than the others yeah I'm going
to win and for that to happen we need to make
you more marketable attractive we need a glow
up for you oh rule number one cover your mouth
people really ain't old up that are you okay
wearing my mama's dress is the only thing keeping
me together here it's like she's wrapping her arms
around me I cannot tell how sincere she is or
if she is intentionally playing him yeah I need
you to sing in these interviews later it's the
night before the games and your last chance to
win people cheapers this move's quick can't send
you gifts in the arena without their money maybe
a guitar could persuade Me Maybe you really want
to take care of me in that Arena corus give me
a fender start by thinking I can actually win no
death coat I know for some reason Rachel zaggler
is a controversial figure but I think she's
the best part of this movie oh yeah I mean
she's really I don't know yeah she's just full of
this uniquely specific distinct pointed life yeah
oh these are the creatures in early devel
early in development that they would put
in the games yeah come and see my new
babies so she is like an evil scientist
yeah my laboratory straight out of a cartoon DD
I know she was just back there stealing Ariel's
voice real quick and now she's in here your
proposal which one of you actually wrote it
well there was was inspired by corus yesterday of
course his little wedding idea yeah yeah so it's
your s writing on that page unfortunately
my assistant was St it there you go there
mhm in line the shelf of this very terrarium
with it oh boy so miss Dove coat retrieve it
for us won't you all consider your inspired
idea really smart really smart to speak up
canot canot read the room could you doel get
those they can trust hey some smart people
are dumb as hell if you've handled their
food for example or if they've inhaled the
sweat of your palm on a page retrieve it
why don't you admit the truth yeah dude
seriously yeah wowe I want my enemies to
see a rainbow of Destruction engulfing
the world will she die the pleasure in
breaking ground in one's researches one
gets to find out you better keep
Miss Dev coat's fate between us I
don't think her mother would be happy
to learn how she'd CAU the sudden flu
oh sorry I'm late enjoy the show I'm enjoying
the weird experiences I'm enjoying the plot a
lot I'm enjoying being back in the world a
lot technically I feel like everything is
really cool I'm still yet to really connect with
any of the characters yeah that's the one part
that I'm like I really need that right sometime
soon it's kind of like a fantastic Beast kind
of Rachel Ziggler's the closest I'm coming yeah
but right now I'm the part emotionally I'm most
compelled by is just what's happening there's
other things emotionally I'm I'm latched on
to wowe welcome to the arena for
the 10th annual Hunger Games you
have 15 minutes to survey the space
and discuss strategy D you stick by
me understand sir yes sir hey Lumberjack
how Gladiator like this feels actually just
you forming their alliances please please
don't let me die in here tomorrow wowe or
today Jesus while the mentors are there
yeah this is all part of the plan I
bet wow is this really happening right now
yeah survey the space wow whoa oh
help me oh how crazy damn in your
position back for help who will the real Mentor
be oh and she goes back to help him she's the
one I'm connected to she's the best come on
the gate's open come on he would have saved
you a scrypto has some like really cheesy
dialogue though they were on set like this
is really going to get to the people really
emphasiz is that you it fluctuates the script
in the dialogue yeah yeah look at her go oh
wow oh no Maloy who is she gray where is she
she's alive what happened it was a rebel bombing
oh they must have been planing it for months
four tributes were killed everyone's terrified
cor B is the last that gives her better
RS oh yeah she's winning right now Felix
Raven Still's on my so boy not Felix Raven still
released a message they said they wanted to tear
down the symbol of The Hunger Games on live TV
you think he's giving them inside knowledge oh
I bet he is he's the only one peacekeepers are
hunting him in the streets but at least he has
a better chance out there than he would tomorrow
tomorrow they're not still going ahead with the
games oh no Lucy gray this is exactly what you
didn't want to happen but she saved me love how
they always say Lucy gray I know she made it clear
can't just say Lucy not Lucy Lucy gray Lucy gray
come out here with that guitar you song bird hey
what' they get her what' they get her did they
get her a hummingbird I do like the oh my God
he's actually she's going to sing I wrote this
song about a boy back in 12 and I hope he hears
it [Music] uhoh 100 donations donations 15,000
[Music]
donations got some pipes
[Music] man I love Dark Country
[Music] yeah oh damn it's a Johnny
Cash tune yeah Sting here thinking do
they write stuff for this or are these
covers wow who she got the 1500 but you know
still not bad pretty close send is that a d
no this is a regular guitar now I don't love
your odds but may they be in your favor oh way
to own that line own that line how wonderful
is it tonight that we all get to be here for
someone's final performance wow dude go to
bed get a good night's sleep you got a big
day tomorrow got a big day to die tomorrow what I
love about the Aesthetics that they've done it's
still futuristic but they've taken like how the
50s imagin the future yeah as like retr futurist
yeah and it feels appropriately like in the past
of the familiar world but still futuristic to now
yeah it's pretty cool just nothing beats
Jennifer Lawrence fing at the mouth in
tears for a whole trilogy you know yeah yeah
yeah you know it's the real heart and soul of the
games but hey man maybe Rachel Ziggler break
down and do like a crazy ass crying scene she's
great I love her character no ideaone else just
about her I love her she you're alive they have
them sleep out there yeah I guess so there's
no other like doors or anything there's a hole
down in the floor leads down to some tunnels
I've tried it and you can disappear down there
what moment you hear that bell rang you ignore
the weapons in the middle and you run as fast
as you can for that hole wow I can't let you
die I love you you saved me let secret maybe
she saved you because she knew she needed you
still hopeful during the daytime but when it
gets darks okay when it gets dark I'll suum
to the darkness me it's okay I really hope
they got this shot authentically I am going to
get you out of here promise back to the Cy okay
oh oh oh he now ready is this real yeah thank
you good question that song that song was payback
that's all my old boyfriend Billy to he was
cheating on me with the mayor's daughter whoa
yeah she got crazy jealous she had her PW read my
name up on that stage and now everyone will know
what they did to me damn she must be using him
or something in some way I mean she just seems
so much kind of sharper and and kind of detached
from the [__] of this than anyone else it is
not a gift it's alone don't touch it don't even
breathe it in because small amounts can be deadly
and there will come a time when you need this
when you need to act we all do things we're
not proud of to survive yeah is Lucy gray doing
that we going to win this she C this a different
shot of her we're going to win this together
it's the electric company Hunger Games Hunger
Games chapter
two oh got a yellow flower today that friend
of yours plin you might want to find him a seat
near the door whoa cuz he's about to be called out
put on blast I'm lucious lucky flickerman oh he's
perfect CU you can still see he's trying to prove
himself yeah in my hand an envelope my prediction
the winner to be opened by me upon the Big Show's
end but how old Stanley Tui supposed to [Laughter]
be how long of a glow up was that really how
much plastic surgery did he have done enjoy the
show I do like like Rachel Z is my favorite colon
Iris colonoscopy snow is great he's he's good I
do feel like we still needed some stronger
scenes with them before I feel like we need
feel a little bit by the Numbers they with them
glue to stick all this together but specifically
between the two of them yeah was the part where
I'm like I know where the plot's going but it
kind of just seems like the mov like we know
where the plot's going but they're not there
a little more meat on it yeah or that way I'm
like o I hope I hope she's not using I want
to I'm more just like I don't know I wonder
instead of like oh I hope more time to test
their actual relationship through other means or
or like have other things intervene that force
them to act off the cuff yeah cuz that's like
the core heart of the struggle here the real
conflict and I do like how like downscaled
these games feel by comparison uh yeah by a
lot they're in one room oh no a symbol out
of him yeah Marcus guess we can all sleep
better now knowing he's off the streets
oh he's going to lose his [__] yeah
you're monsters all of you I'm on your side I
thought he was the kid from strangers when we
saw the trailer he does look like thought
it was the whole time game mazzo shouts
out 2 1 [Music] sing O then the movie get
begin yeah what are you doing FR nah man
she can't leave her dude behind oh how
barbaric this wide angle lens too it's
just like a Royal Rumble in here yeah
who nice yesh ah Trident what's his
name oh the bow and arrow so many
Easter eggs that was an instant
vomit seems like it's going to be
a very short Hunger Games oh Jesus
jeez just wandering around over there wow what a
great [Music] shot I killed a man with a trident
Rick killed a guy uhoh oh what you're seeing
now is a live feed of security cameras come
on oh boy oh boy high and soft NE other side
pining in on Lucy graay pining very tactical
oh she can squeez through can Jessup damn it dude
pull him ah no no no no kick him kick his faceing
high oh you can feel that like what the
hell happened her where they stab her I
would have stabbed her right in the butt this
my one opportunity see what this is like six
tributes gone in minutes if they keep it up at
this page we're going to be out of here in no
time
wow oh my dude is he asking for death
yeah send your money now once they get your
money Mentor can choose to send in food or
water reprogrammed with facial recognition
this shures that your package goes directly
to your tribute isn't that right Pap Herington
yeah yeah the hell out of my face the first
drone [Music] oh cut her hand off wow yeah what
the [__] they did not master drone technology
hey the facial recognition do it did its thing
so we don't have to worry about that anymore
what do you want from that girl nothing I
want her to live and the plen prize would
be a happy coincidence I suppose I believe I'd
be entitled to it prize the girl how convenient
you don't have to choose between them ouch who
do you think makes that final decision for the
prize you so covet Mr snow wake up even if Lucy
gy beard somehow wins it all I will do everything
in my power to Ure that you don't see a dime
why do he have against this guy yeah what' he
do to you how much how much do you care if
she lives now more is that the answer more
what did you sacrifice to make sure she could
live and then she betrayed you I just want to
S oh boy you know what's in that water what
have you done to it I didn't do anything
Jess you okay I did I did Endeavor to save you
and to share this space with you s breadcrumbs
I believe sustenance for a fallen comrade on
his final journey of District 2 Superstition
whoa I need someone to get him out right now
you should send peacekeepers in only to have
him bolt and hide like a rabbit ug Felix
Raven steal his fighting for his life in a
hospital Mr snow I will not have these Rebels
make a further mockery of my games oh you get
them out unscathed I whisper your name in his
father's ear uh-oh and he has more power than
Peter Dinklage I'll freeze the feed for an hour
I estimate that's all we have until the people
notice whoa all the manipulations and minations
of high society I think Gary Ross directed the
first Hunger Games movie and Francis Lawrence
directed the rest and I kind of feel like this
needs a touch of what Gary Ross's Direction was
yeah where you really feel like you're there on
ground observing this yeah I think I need a
little bit of that grit that Gary Ross brings
but this movie does prove that you can continue
on The Hunger Games movies and World Without You
Know Jennifer Lawrence yeah you still make
this is still like an interesting film yeah
and you know you get your social commentary
in there sort of same social commentary the
other ones more overt slightly updated
to include drones and facial recognition
technology I mean no they they just dro
Dro drones in the they did the drones in
the other one this is like the origin of it
yeah or something right they Che them yeah
they have those little like thingies that'll
bring you stuff they work you need to go Coro
I promise to get you up I have to do this
I had to go where the cameras are you think
anyone's watching this do you want to fight
these tributes or fight for them because if
you want to make real change you need to
stay alive how can I make any change from
out there you're rich you're the only one who
stood up to go in that class right yeah you
got to lead the Rebellion out there dog better
hurry up man come with me spend your father's
money do some real good I'll just be another
dead body in Gs one trust me come on man go
go oh jeez wow enjoy the show oh my God you can't
you can't kill him yeah oh
no I don't want to hurt you
yeah dude in the face dog oh
he mad whoa dude this is bad
this is very bad move over the gate oh maybe
theate maybe that was a hint of the disdain
that he actually does feel towards them my
father my father let the buying begin I feel so
bad for these spoiled Rich Kids yes who clearly
understand the full extent of the system within
the which they exist it's weird when the people
from The Districts got when the people from
The Districts first got reeled in they were
portrayed as humans now that the games started
they portrayed as like Savage villains what the
[__] just happened or is it intention that
when you switch perspectives of that you know
I don't know you get what I mean they stop being
human and all us they were just Savages yeah yeah
yeah where they all just kind of feel like a
big gang of like rabid feral people villains
yeah no I did definitely I I remember in the
other movies like them having this sort of
you know nasty gang mentality here and there but
yeah it felt like we were fighting morlocks just
now yeah see how quickly civilization disappears
yeah fight or flight those tributes don't have a
choice I was talking about you oh all your fine
manners education background she witnessed she
witnessed with the club who beats another boy
to death to stay alive yeah was a test you want
to protect people Mr snow protect the games
to govern them like your father oh and it's
essential you accept what human beings are
animals and what it takes to control them
television oh oh got to make enough Hunger
Games money to save the rec center they sent
me into the Arena tonight tigers are you okay
I killed one of the tributes damn and it felt
like a release powerful oh yeah look out you
got your first taste I'm going back in yeah I
got to get back in there you don't have to pay
the same price just to survive people can be
good you can be good you are good okay it's your
villain origin story man something scintilating
occurred bobin from District slaughtered wow
people cheering they aren't showing us what
happened to that little boy he clearly was killed
right there there's cameras everywhere they said
there were old cameras liy probably just another
one of corals Fus sit down they haven't moved an
inch or hunger dementia what' you do to me ly what
is he doing something's wrong he he wouldn't turn
on her like what did you do to me what did who do
to you someone must have done something folding it
in itself wait look the phone I think it's rabies
oh my rabies it makes you afraid of water send him
a drone scar him yes away from her oh my Vick's
going for her community pad early I don't have
any idea fly a drone right into him what's wrong
with me I guess that's what I mean is like here
they specify oh oh yeah oh and then we offered her
water yeah like Mary Magdalene oh look out yeah
they specify drones from the war here I feel like
that's that's more pointed oh yeah well that's
the thing is they do have like gladiator weapons
too like at least inspired by the different casts
of Gladiators in ancient Rome packing it in Lucy
gray swarmed cornered M propeller sending a drone
his community I'm going to flood the room hey
Crow do you mind if I take this one not a chance
wow wow
Jesus hey free water water
hydrate they must have should
have stipulated something it's
a that's a little too much involvement I think
yeah develop the telepathic
link it's a terrible hiding spot
yeah it's not a good high ground do
now
oh [__] me she seems like a good
person yesh oh that trident is very
effective whoa oh damn so smart oh you're
cruel oh you real cruel I legit get
out of these balls wake up grab and
put a little wake up let me go up here
they'll want to get their water yeah
what she can stab through that oh damn did
you get a finger in there you really think
you deserve that water now Tanner let's all
share the water look you just said watch the
beam H Coro it's w a [__]
what oh no why did she step
out yeah come on now seven tributes remain that's
annoying oh she's going to
try to drink the water damn
it oh that is
sad he's just going to lay
down what happened maybe they'll all
just have a sip of the water and just
all over I got to hydrate my brain so I can think
straight how could they not be viewed
as humans before I don't know well I
mean that's what classism does to you as
long as there is a ladder there will be
someone there to look down it and say
not you or is he going to give them a
[Music] p yeah man a little Mass grave are you
going to punish me now my dude he's
cool Felix Raven son of our beloved
president sustained in the rebel bombing wow no
Phoenix Raven still they will be celebrating this
young boy's death as a Triumph wow not allow
my games to give our enemy such a victory they
will not spoil the fun before the sun goes
down tonight a rainbow of Destruction will
engulf our Arena the rainbow of Destruction it's
back there's to be no Victor in these game dude
what oh boy what is the motive here got to show
absolute power so this is a very pivotal [Music]
game there a Tracker in him I need to see
Dr G immediately yeah she's taking uh she's
completely open schedule right here that
announc video her phone's not been ringing
off the hook no one's tried to this first one
to try to see I thought I would have visitors
out the door no my stitches they broke
close come sit hold down your shirt yeah
Seducer song birds and cages this might hurt
what are we doing here they got to transport
that to OC Corp Tower jabber Jays we called
them Ming J sent them out during the war to
pick up Rebel conversations squawk it
back to us word for word wow whoa cool
that's really cool was there a bird in in the
arena there must have been a failed experiment
but an instructive one I'm rounding them up
District by District now to see what better
purposes they might serve what a great form of
surveillance failed experiment but an instructive
one so are they fully organic or digitally
integrated or both uh it's the hunger gam Ser
both o i mean maybe I wouldn't be right next to
the vent yeah you got a whole lot of space like
you should at least check that out over the one
the one stabbing spot baby you don't want to be
at oh yeah put the hanky in there
so they know her and they love
her that's not a bad plan it's one
little thing everyone's going to
pass it around yeah good mcgu snakes
are all going to pass that one little
C it smelled as [__] man SM I
smelled you before just smell as
[__] how much more heroin do
I have oh damn what's wrong with
Treach woo boy oh boy Jesus oh boy [Music]
no of the snakes yeah buddy Snakes on a
drone did every snake get a chance with that
hanky a oh yeah oh wow what a way to
go oh oh oh Jesus super snakes
they kind of look like uh the candy yeah like uh
the trolly uh uh Creepy Crawlers candy snakes it's
not matter it's not I can't have killed them all
for nothing wow that's what the system will do to
you Creepy Crawlers and is goodbye to Festus
Creed have a nice summer now all colors lead to
Gray he's like he's proud of himself
that's a good one it's a good one
flickerman we worship you oh [Music]
graybeard oh no you're going to make
her martyr if you let her die man before I can f
of don't you go she won it's over
let her out wer yeah why aren't they
attacking her must be the singing
it's calming them she can't sing
forever she got to sing with that accent [Music]
too
she's moving everyone dude
yeah go
girl oh damn she she's scaring
me goosebumps like twice
man oh that
shot oh this is like like what legendary
stories are made of yeah big sacrifices
I wonder if they sang if she sang this like
on set in camera cuz it's like so performed
through the emotion of her character
get her out get her out you're going
to make her a goddamn enemy call dude
what are you doing yeah dude make the
call call yeah get her out there go get
her out get her out there was Lucy gray
yeah get she's won Lucy gray for
let us know is the winner of the
10th annual Hunger Games but Cory Elena
still loses his mentorship competition
yeah there's still like an hour left of
the movie I know what else is there to
do then he became an evil dictator elect this man
let him lead us uhoh oh damn it uh oh you cheated
H yep cheating will be punished yep yep yep isy
gray where is she I would be more concerned with
your own Survival if I were you we both know
that child from 11 in diet disease and that old
handkerchief founded in the snake tank condemning
you with your father's own initials so it was
still in the tank yeah a handkerchief yeah they
must have just all passed it around didn't get
like Swept Away in any of that just left it right
there on the bottom I've decided banishment to
the districts will you serve your capital in exile
for the next 20 years as an anonymous peacekeeping
grunt damn he's going to make you a stormtrooper
dude you hear that boy finally the sound of snow
falling hey it falls on top yeah snow falls top
chapter three snow falls on top whoa oh buddy
a full on prisoner yeah so James what are you
doing what do you think what I did in the arena
my father had to buy the academy a brand new gym
just I could get my diploma begged me to stay but
once I found out where they were sending you I
couldn't get out fast enough my man figure I get
through basic and then maybe I become a medic
make a real difference out here just like you
said a it's good to see you smile man I cheated
save Lucy Gray from the snakes and I do it again
do you think they killed her she was a big hit if
there is a games next year they're probably going
to invite her to sing at the opening ceremony a
she's going to love that when the girl you risked
everything for might be waiting for you at the
end of this trap my friend don't give them the
satisfaction your life has just begun you're going
to do great she has a whole family name yeah how
does a guy like this climb back in power I mean
he must wind up being some in some unique position
to mediate between the furthest reaches of the
rebellion and the innermost core of society must
exploit something welcome to 12 for the next many
years brothers and sisters in your immediate Squad
will become your family you will train together
sleep together eat together you will rise together
and you will fall together touch yourselves
together and it will be your duty to report
anything suspicious you see because if you do not
you are as good as a rebel yourself Burn Gorman
a peacekeeper and two mind bosses were shot dead
that this man all out chance is guilty oh run run
ah you're
murderer the birds are listening spy Birds
yeah jabber what were you thinking back there
she didn't do anything Coro what do she kill
to you being directly associated with Rebels
if she had gotten through the crowd I don't
think I would have been able to shoot her you
need to find a way to make peace with our life
here now W H's giving us all leave passes for
the weekend boost morale we're going to Hogs
me yeah they need a morale boost yeah these
guys clearly downtrodden yeah does make sense
though like he would this whole experience
allowed him to get the most involved with
understanding the full breadth of the whole
society from Top how to govern well how to
govern over yeah how to Wrangle and maintain
oh there's music Lucy Great Bear
could be here [Music] here cuz
we're planning on heating it up a let's go no
one here we go get that new
guitar you need a bird you need like a
hummingbird or a dove like there a lot
of bird themed guitars I bet you never
expected to lay eyes on me again and let
me tell you that goes both ways but I am
back oh come on y'all you know I gave up
drinking when I was 12 I wonder if she's been
brainwashed or like controlled by the capital
in some way yeah leveraged and or more
likely leveraged than indoctrinated but
[Music] yeah [Music] oh she got a great
voice God damn all them blue not like
every song she's been given yeah when
she's going to bring that Soulful bluesy
quality with like Broadway Precision are
these original songs I don't know if they
yeah I don't know like they sound like they
could be just like you know songs passed down
it's go take I feel like the lyrics
kind of suggest that it's a it's an
original song like written recently but
it sound like they could be about her it
could be about they could be about snow like
Snow's perspective get that accordion boy oh
Jesus swear you wouldn't play with
them again Billy to B Jesus oh dude
save the accordion ow I know you missed
me Luc keep your hands off me right now
oh that's the xoh uhoh uhoh I will snake I
will oh dude yeah get off get off what are
you crazy come on we got here wow was that close
to her this is really interesting there's like
three different movies in here yeah each Act
own little movie each chapter really [Music]
interesting around the Hanging Tree swaying
in the breeze I love every kind of song she
was given yeah still got one foot in the
arena God how beautiful the country there
is a bit of like a classic southern tale they
tell with her breaking their rules saving your
life but I gave them my last scent so that
I could come here to 12 because I had to try
to find you cuz I love you my Dean he told me
the strangest thing he said he was glad that I
survived you what ouch I didn't have a choice
that little girl D I know I thought it'd be
one of the others maybe you are not a killer
Lucy gr yes I am did what I had to do you're
safe I don't trust anything around
her there are no bars preventing you
now your Peacekeeper friends I'll handle this
hey they can't see us together there's a lake
out in the woods a nobody knows much of it
except usby meet me here tomorrow we'll go
it'll be our special place it's a romantic drama
between them it's funny it's it would have been
cool to see some of this perspective on her life
in the earlier part of the story but I get why
you can't really put it there but I feel like
it might have been a good thing to do earlier
on for her character figured you'd be a while
so I decided to Spore town with Billy to who's
the other guy with him I remember that the
academy watching watch everyone oh carefully
choosing when the way in are you trying to help
these people don't you think they need help they
lost the war s Janice before they started that
made your family Rich throw away any chance I
might have of getting home someday just because
you feel a bit guilty good point turn [Music]
coming I wrote this song about [Music] me
oh my God they're in like casual
garb one by the Drone Just Hits
him the Forbidden Love red on black
friend to Jack I guess she just wasn't
using him or something I guess not
it's just an actual romance between
them D I'm going to get the soundtrack yes it's
great I love I love the songs Mocking Jays we call
them mocking everyone cheered in the theater
stood up and threw their po that's part one
and that's part two I'm sure she's out there
somewhere she's a Survivor but it's a mystery
sweetheart just like me whenever you look down
in the sand and see one set of footprints Lucy
gray was carrying you the whole time would
you really go back though if you could to
the capital I have to you have no idea ug but I
hope you'll come back with me capital's not for
me is it civilized has Ord The Hunger Games
are order yeah what cuss of course not what
if this was our life corus not here it's not
coralus it's Slim Shady now I got a new name
all right it's a little early at M Ivory early
for what to eat the roots pretty little thing
but it's determined J all just like you
some people call it swamp potato I think
Katniss has a much nicer ring don't you catniss
everyone took out their guns and fired into the
[Laughter] theaters oh where where's
the everin Now find an everan he misses
Billy tote do you this right here
eat up bread there's a gale coming
down hey Mitch could you pass me
that you can trust me I promise you that if you
can trust anyone in this world you can trust me
no those wide lenses I maybe I don't know one
of the best things about what's happening with
this movie is I cannot predict what is going
to happen that leads to him becoming the snow
that we know yeah yeah there's the one thing
I I can't I was like obviously going to live
whatever but I I have no idea what it leads to
I received the results from your aptitude test
this morning over your training records too
your performance is exemplary well the other
recruits can't read sir you're General crus SS
boy crus what did you do to end up here I made
an enemy sir I've made a career out of ruining
my enemy's plans I'm going to help you son yeah
I'm going to reassign you to officer training in
District 2 you'll real wage no nope train leaves
in 10 days keep a clean record you'll never see
anyone from District 12 again as God intended
this is an honor private not option yes sir that
that's actually a really good line yeah totally
said honor not an option really speaks to the
the tone of this Society especially where are
you great we're fine tigers where are you we're
underground we had to move out we're renting
this place just for right now they evicted you of
course they did Grand's fine I really don't want
you to worry I think I found a way out of here
I just have to make it through officer training
and two and then I can make my way back to
the capital I will fix this don't make me
hope what HOH who you talking to I
think that girl who's caged Oh Yeah from
before them special Birds I saw you talking to
that woman in the jail if I don't report you
now you don't know anything to report they know
we're friends you're going to get us both killed
you told me I could do something you told me I
could make a difference well you're rebelling
though you're not using your power they're going
up north to start a new life far away from PanAm
they need money for supplies they told me I could
go if I got it for them you could come with us
you're giving money to the locals do not record
this dog they're not planning on doing anything
dangerous okay it's all dangerous they're just
doing what anybody else would do Coro the leader
Spruce he wants to get his sister Lil out of
jailon Base Hoff is going to execute her just
because she knows the man that they killed dude
you're totally betraying him what if they catch
you bringing this woman off base it's worth
the risk to do the right thing for you it's
never worth a risk play the long game and don't
get anything done in the process don't make me
rescue you again I don't need you to rescue me
Coro boy damn dude now just leave the recording
on for the whole transport process like max out
the memory on this poor bird they're just doing
what anybody else would do cor you the leader
Spruce he wants to get a sister out of jail
on do he like trim it down or is he just going
to send it as is he didn't do anything wrong
well yeah and she knows about him going in
already she suggested that so I guess he's
fine but it's these kind of Acts that would
make her not trust him and not want to be with
him Lu right yeah oh 100 100% I mean this is
going to drive them apart [Music] completely
a she's sicking to you [__] that's my girl
up there she sing about me that's my woman
talk about me up there now I'm now part of
District 12 just let me get one last look at
you a snow is born what are you doing guns sanus
I know there was going to be weapons Coro they
lied to me you thought they'd be honest are you
crazy there are peacekeepers right out there
there's another one in here now too okay oh yeah
it's okay Spruce he's with me he I I told him to
come in here he's going to he don't be wor she's
okay Spruce she's joining us too she's with me she
what quiet down neor I'll explain later it's my ex
I'm trying to get her back man she be C my rebound
making me look stupid what do you think Lucy gray
mom talk no action hey how' you enjoy the capital
by the way what did you do see yall at the Hanging
Tree whoa yeah buddy oh my [__] yeah hell's
breaking loose now what did you just do well you
just shot the mayor's daughter son what did you
just do want a rebel before you are now freak
Dam this on Me Maybe I said pop down C surprise
coming Capital boy if I'm going to swing for this
you swing with me oh no dude wow [__] it's The
Departed look at me you're going to go back
out on that stage and you're going to sing
you're going to get your goddamn [__] together
yeah my hand never shakes you're going to sing
like nothing is wrong and I'm going to find us a
way out of this okay okay I I swear I swear get
rid of these guns now he's got to clean up this
mess if you breathe a word now both of us we're
finished so we go back out there and act like
nothing is wrong you have to pull it together you
came here for me right we're brothers so whatever
you've done I swear I will keep you safe wow he's
making a promise that he knows he's not going to
be able to keep up yeah those guns were the only
loose end besides the four of us so we're going
to be okay not a word okay okay at the end of
the day he's only going to look out for himself
it's like that Mentor ship slingshotted him into
just being a manipulator and a plotter H is losing
his mind mind the mayor's daughter got shot in her
boyfriend too he's sending out every grunt we've
got to find the guns that did it oo my palms are
sweaty on my uniform already we shall find their
murder weapons if the killers are still in PM's
grasp they will hang before the week is out oh
boy you okay mayor's going to get me killed G
lus you already think it it's me Billy tote
mayther both dead they cat Spruce no sanus to
the Jus won't talk how do you know that trust
me he won't yeah I'm so sorry I should have
dealt with those guns myself I have to run north
that really hope and the others talked about if I
stay here now I'm as good as de what about the Cy
they can look after each other just wanted to say
goodbye be targets without me I'll come with
you I just learned Hoff is sending me to tube
for officer training but none of that matters
now you were going to leave it's all PanAm as
soon as they find that gun they'll hang me
no matter which district I'm in I think we
got one 3 years I fought for the capital during
the war oh I was going to let someone else take
it this is the first time I felt ashamed oh get
the other one up here yeah it's a big old Gap
there Capital has received word via Jabba
J that these two men conspire to break
into our basis jail and flee North a you
messed up dude expect this of a reel but
not from one of our own this is treas
does he know who that's who's his son
is the leader Spruce he wants to get his
sister Lil out of jailon Base oh that is
bad oh wow they played it but they
they didn't play his a part of the
Audio I feel like everything post
The Hunger Games of this has been
the most [Laughter] interesting this is
the part that's breathing the most and
also like doing something completely
different from the other ones yeah
yeah dude you like straight up
betrayed him yeah dude this is all on
you this man is like Master at sneaking
I know there's a whole bunch of dudes
[Music] around I love the songs in this movie
they are all so good and they they've naturally
found a way to like weave them through
the whole thing and it's like not quite
a musical but still kind of cuz like it's yeah
it's such a strong element there's emotion to
it man there's movement it's like completely
rooted in the story and it creates a tone to
the film yeah it's rooted in her emotion sure
will be nice not to have to kill anyone else up
north though huh three's enough for me dude
why that phrase who's the third what person
you killed lanus he said you killed three people
I only know about two do not lie to me oh yeah
my old self I killed him so I could come with
you clever yeah speak poetic she don't buy it
though very clever man we're going to need
food let's catch some fish while we're here
storm clouds gathering over your relationship
if you want to fish there's rods under the
floorboards I brought you this delicious
bass it break to you guys there's I like
I I like them both individually they're is
a lack of like romantic chemistry with them
though yeah it's like fine it's like passing
great you know but I really feel like this
has to be compelling yeah you got to like
love the romance enough that it's going to
be completely heartbreaking when the inevitable
happens the one you fired at Mayfair Spruce must
have known about this place if we destroy
that gun you're free you can go back home
no besides me ug you wouldn't tell anyone of
course not song birds for singing I'm just
going to go dig up some catness yeah down by
the lake thought it was too early for that the
world changes awful fast that grin it's still
raining well I'm not made out of sugar I would
love if this just became an evil dead movie
right now St was in there with the guns he did
it come you'll see m a scarf I do like the
trajectory of oh my god wow damn is that
poisonous I said are you trying to kill me after
everything I've done for you he did do a lot for
you it's turning into like a tense domestic
threr yeah there the movies doing something
really interesting where he starts off as like
you know that pompous arrogant first class and
then the more he becomes like the dark villain
the more human he actually seems yeah you watch
him flirt with the different ideologies until
finally we get here but he seems like more like a
guy now than he did at the beginning even though
he's worse yeah he's like becoming like full a
villain wow what a shot went right for for it
wow uhoh something to remember
you by that's enough Lucy great
I said birds whistling along is it a
recording I don't know I guess must
be oh oh that's what I spend my time doing in Red
Dead Redemption damn Birds he got to shoot the
birds it's like the saturation tone down
there then Jason comes
upks it's the only thing we haven't done
with Friday the 13th yet Jason gets a
gun
gummy berry juice I mean he got rid of the loose
ends of the guns but he would need to kill her
yeah especially now how's the arm private medic
said you took quite a bite nothing that I won't
have forgotten about by the time I reached tomb
there's been a change of plan private snow what
we're creating a special district and putting
you in it it's 15 congratulations Mr snow you've
passed all my tests so you'll be studying under me
now at the Capital University what was the rest of
the test I can't afford University a certain Mr
stro plinth has offered to pay for everything you
need while you're there wow all for being such
a good friend to his s Janus he doesn't know
quite how good a friend you were of course yeah
you sent your only friend to the Noose just to
get impressive that's not what I did are you sure
because I think that won you the plin prize after
all wow whoa what a curse president has agreed to
another year of the games people watched we got
picked up but before I take you under my wing
after everything you've seen out there in the
real world let me ask you one final time what
are The Hunger Games about what are the Hunger
Games for I used to think that the Hunger Games
Were punishment for the district then I thought
they served as a warning to us here in the capital
about the threat the districts posed little bit
each now I know the whole world is an arena and
we need the Hunger Games to remind us all who
we truly are we need the annual Purge who are
you do you determine the Victor welcome home Mr
[Laughter] snow
wow the world is The Hunger Games you look just
like your father corus in the end he became his
father and we know what she thinks of his father
we know she wasn't talking about the clothes he
was wearing talkinging about the hate in his
eyes your Twisted Soul wake up sanus plint
personal effects from District 12 what's going
going to return this to his parents tonight as a
gift would have been his 19th birthday but I think
they would prefer just this H Jesus best friends
forever you grew a heart in the districts no not
in the districts in The Hunger Games I should be
thanking you credit for the Hunger Games goes
to your father half of it at least I only jumed
them up as an assignment whoa oh no oh my God I
was drunk devise a punishment for our enemies so
extreme they will never forget how badly they've
wronged us no one could actually agree when I
sobered up I wanted it destroyed but your father
my best friend sto from me wow damn put both our
names on it taking it to G to rise up himself she
put it in a snake tank I hope the games might die
out I tried to stop them however I could but
then you came along now the blood of so many
more Generations will be on my hand hands yeah my
contacts informed me that she's disappeared that
the mayor might have killed her out there but
there's no proof it's mystery she is a mystery
her daddy's name look at you air to the plint
fortune Nothing in Your Way snow lands on top
God damn right got to respect the game yeah
that's true respect the game don't knock the
hustle oh no Peter Dinklage man he did seem like
he wanted it the from very beginning or like
yeah surrender find your
peace whoa that was a good effect actually the
way they made him go like cold and purple and
bruis around the eyes yeah it's really good
color fading from his face snowfall symbolism
he's changed the entire weather pattern
of the capital soon this Fountain will be
covered in ice and a rainbow of Destruction
per it's the things we love most D Tri us
oh look
out and you love Lucy gray the theme awesome we
did it we made it wow all right reject Nation so
today I want to share something with you that
has been a wonderful addition to my health and
fitness journey that I discovered during the
holidays and that is liquid IV's hydration
multiplier I'm down to my very last packet
and I'm freaking out but it's okay I got more
in the mail now a lot of you have been so kind
to notice how I've been working on my physical
health thank you for all the compliments and
one thing I learned is that proper hydration
is absolutely crucial especially post-workout
and pre-filming after post-workout and my wife
actually introduced me to this product which is
perfect because we not only care about quality
but a good taste and quality product whether it's
after a sweaty workout or just after you know a
good night out you know what I'm saying efficient
hydration and replenishing electrolytes is key you
just feel better and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough another thing I'm always on
the lookout for too is products that have zero
sugar or zero sugar added because that's one
of my main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products that fit
that description that also tastes good too so
yes thank you so much so liquid IVs hydration
multiplier is in summary is they are non-GMO
electrolyte drink that delivers hydration into
your bloodstream faster and more efficient than
water alone sometimes drinking a whole gallon
is not always efficient but in fact it can
provide the same hydration as drinking two to
three bottles of water I'm also big on efficiency
plus it's packed with the love essential vitamins
and we know vitamins are good for the body it's
vegan soy free gluten- free and dairy free you
can customize the water amount to your taste again
perfect for post night recovery traveling or just
having a big night out you know what I mean no
so if you want a booster support for the channel
and booster hydration game go to liquid i.com and
use promo code Rejects at checkout that's liquid
i.com promo code Rejects and remember liquid IV
it's not a real IV sure feels like it so stay
hydrated stay healthy and let's keep crushing
those health and fitness goals together in the
year 2024 all righty well well reject Nation uh
if you're listening to us on Apple or Spotify we
just literally moment to go finish watching
Hunger Games Ballad of song birds and snake
all righty well um before going into it my
expectations were they were tampered well like
there was a good trailer and then there were not
great reviews mixed reviews I would say but then
a really good audience score and then the box
office ended up picking up on it so I was like
all right well this sets my expectations I feel
like that's all I really knew I didn't watch any
reviews so I didn't know what people thought about
anything in particular and then I just was able to
take this one down now just little reminder like
I've only I think I might have seen the first one
twice I think I saw the first one twice yeah
yeah I definitely saw the first one twice and
then I saw the other ones just one time and uh
I really love the first two a lot I remember uh
really loving them yeah this isn't going to be
really a comparison uh to them there's no real
point in doing that uh but there were there's a
lot about this movie that I really really liked uh
quite quite a bit and there are some things that
I'm like H I feel like maybe they wor maybe two
and a half hours is actually not enough to tell
this epic spanning tale that they want to tell and
then it seems like it even ends at a point where
they would still do his equal yeah to the the the
rise of snow I think they were smart enough to go
we'll just try this one movie that we jam-packed
out and then if people like that then we'll do our
corol is snow Trilogy yeah yeah yeah instead of
announcing it ahead of time I mean but what did
what are your what's the first thing that comes
to mind for you John oh goodness I mean I guess
Rachel Ziggler is the first thing that comes to
mind uh yeah I quite enjoyed this too uh in an
interesting way cuz yeah like The Hunger Games
franchise for me you know I I like I probably
had the same experience that I think about it
like I might have seen Catching Fire or the first
one again at home you know on home video at some
point but I feel like I the first one was a pretty
vivid experience when it was out the second one
like I'll never forget the IMAX experience of that
yeah and then the the the returns you know kind of
diminished across the mocking Chase uh but yeah
so I I I came in kind of in a in a middle space
you know sort of being like yeah I'm I'm happy to
go back to this world I'm not expecting the moon
and I've heard enough mixed opinions some people
really positive some people kind of met that I
was like yeah this this is a fun Prospect to me
because it could go any number of directions and
it sounds like they're at least trying something
and uh and yeah like it's interesting because
those two performances at the center of the movie
are so much of you know what makes it compelling
I mean like the the the world and the way that
they talking about snow and Lucy gray yeah okay
Lucy greybeard uh you know those two com I I I
I agree when you say that this could have been
longer just because I feel like we really see
from the perspective of snow we really get to
know snow and I wish we could have maybe done that
for Lucy gray as well because Rachel zler does
have this fascinating presence in the movie as it
is presented because she is kind of like a bird
flying through everything uh because she's removed
from everything like she comes from these people
who exist outside of and sort of in between the
different districts and then you have the district
setup that we know about but we're largely seeing
from the perspective of somebody who is from that
Upper Crust and who you know has even if he's
got you know uh shambled Origins is certainly
Arisen to you know the kind of the heights of
privilege and whatever else in this society and
so like when they first meet and she enters the
plot like she is such a presence and such a force
but I feel like there it's like the problem is
we need our own like Katniss everine Style movie
to show her life outside of this too cuz like the
way she enters the movie she does have this kind
of like magic presence cuz you know she's going
to teach him but she's also got to survive the
Hunger Games but she also just has this just sort
of effervescent wiseness in in all situations that
sort of places her I don't know yeah just in this
interesting plane above it all while still very
much entrenched in it all so yeah I feel like some
of the character things could have benefited from
the kind of breathing room the third chapter gets
which I'm glad they put it there because it's what
you're going to leave people off you know it's
the last taste you're going to leave in their
mouth and it's certainly sort of a very tangible
uh sequence uh that part of the story and you do
get more of that sense of like the life that this
girl comes from and and the way he looks at that
and all those interesting things but but the
performances I thought were really terrific the
performances were I thought everyone was great
in this movie yeah even to even Viet Davis are
usually can't do anything wrong with me she's the
only one I was questionable about did she did she
for sure know the world the tone of like yes there
are HID in characters in Hunger Games for sure but
there's kind of like a time and a place for where
they are placed she's not doing like hoyy toyy
heighten she's doing like she something else yeah
she's doing like a whole other she reminded me of
Charlie there in Snow White and the Huntsman
where she's just like way elevated and chewing
scenery in a way most other characters are not
yeah but I found it very amusing she was very
entertaining and she had her scenes where she
was effective yeah and I I like I think for me
you know while we're on this subject of all them
yeah like I think the individual performances of
both of them were really good who plays Snow yeah
what is that guy's name i' never I don't know if
I've seen this guy before probably have he's one
of those guys probably I'm like oh yeah I have but
I didn't I didn't remember has he done a game of
throne or something I don't know this guy's name
yeah Tom blle Tom ble that name sounds familiar
does he maybe get like thrown out there for lots
of things no I haven't seen anything this guy's
done actually looking at looking at his list of
stuff I haven't seen any of this yeah damn first
time this is first time for us yeah first time
for us uh yeah I mean I thought he did a really
good job and I thought she did a really good job
and I think like the missing piece for me between
the two of them uh really was just and a lot of
it comes down to the writing the breathing with
then your first um because there's three parts
to hear so three long acts is what they're doing
and and I think like in the First Act especially
they really could have utilized building that
relationship up yeah with them it's more about
like the qualitative treatment that you give them
with The Spar time they are allowed to see each
other you know and they're talking about like oh
Mentor mentee uh Dynamic and they don't really I
I don't feel like we really did enough with that
that the part where I felt like they were really
missing something when it seemed like that would
have been your most compelling story to element
to build the relationship between the two of them
because they want to do two things right they want
to tell the story of the origin of snow but also
the origin of how The Hunger Games came to be I
think the one thing I was misled by and I kind
of blame the trailer I think the trailer makes
it feel this way that this was going to be the
first Hunger Games yeah I thought I thought this
would be the first that was the impression I was
left with was oh we're going to watch the story of
the very first Hunger Games yeah and what did that
look like yeah I didn't realize it' be 10 years in
we still get the origin of how it came to be and
and how it even correlates more with snow haha in
a way that was uh pretty surprising and it like
that reveal at the end of he is a special yeah
your dadicated these games your father was Obi-Wan
Kenobi yes you are monarch son yeah yeah there was
there was the a nice little treatment there uh
but I I do think that what they did miss out on
was really capturing that to hide in everything
tension Stakes the that prequel fear syndrome
where you're like I know he's going to be bad but
I don't want him to be you have to like tug at
that you know and that's where I thought some
of the qual where where some of the emotional
heft was missing some of its zest yeah oh good
word personally that's just my personal take and
it's kind of odd to say that when the individual
performances themselves like isolator or I thought
were really good Rachel zler especially I thought
was a scene stealer and and I I know you keeps I
understand your perspective there of wanting to
see a little bit more from Rachel Ziggler's POV
but I I this choice to keep it this whole thing
feels like it's entirely in Snow's perspective
even when you cut to Rachel zegler in the arena or
hiding out I'm like well there's cameras on there
that he could be watching you know so it's still
his perspective so like even choices like that
make sense to me I don't I can't recall a scene in
here where you actually cut away from a scene that
he is not either privy to or uh like he has to be
in the room in some way yeah yeah and and honestly
I don't beg grudged the movie I understand that
the structure they've chosen necessitates that
and I don't think that's the only way to do it I
feel like yeah if the First Act and by extension
the second but like one thing the later games the
earlier movies do which I get is not fully formed
yet that's part of the point of these but you
know you spend a distinct amount of time with
the mentors you know so like and then they become
distinct characters and so I like the idea of them
being thrown together and them essentially like
meeting as she's getting off the train then being
thrown into this truck and then being thrown into
the zoo and I feel like if we could have stole in
a few more moments to it's weird it's like there
are a lot of things about it that necessitate that
quickness of pace and we're rushing into this and
there's not really much time anyway but it would
have been nice I think to have a couple of scenes
that just made it so that we maybe didn't have to
spend so much time wondering if she is you know
being straight with how she's expressing herself
cuz there are certain times and and I and I think
there's a certain amount of time you're supposed
to be wondering oh are they both playing the game
um and and you know seeing from his it's weird
yeah it's it's good like I think they've given us
a good amount of like kind of Rich stuff there but
yeah like some more intimate beats early on that
breath the little that allow them to establish the
chemistry and allow us to Care just about them
being together Beyond all of this well the the
issue I think with the movie is is another even
though it's a long movie I mean nowadays it feels
like the standard for films are like two and a
half or three hours and I think this should have
been three hours because unlike the other Hunger
Games movies specifically referencing the first
two those first two that Fe like mocking jay
does not have a Hunger Game in it those first
two movies have a Hunger Game in it and the
structure with that is introduce characters
lead into the h games the fun ceremony stuff and
whatever and then you're in The Hunger Games and
there's like a a 5 to 10 minute wrap up at the
end yeah those are both those movies yeah you
know and then here you're do it all that and then
another hour whole movie The this is the rare time
because people used to roll their eyes about the
whole like oh split the last one into two but I'm
like you could split this in two and really stack
up all the because all those happen to favor one
side or the other there's always one half that's
a little more action-packed there's always one
half that's a little more emotional a little more
story and stakes and so like I feel like here you
could have had your thrilling first installment
of like oh man we're getting to see the both of
them we're getting to see him learning how this
world works and his place in it and the moral
implications of all that plus them just bonding
over getting through this Hunger Game and then
the next side okay they're free they're back in
the district they're about to gear this up again
you know will he you know we know where he's
headed but then you can spend that movie going
oh will they remain you know together yeah cuz I
didn't even feel I I don't really care for um I'm
not one of those people who really thinks that a
movie needs to do commentary I do think that when
you are I'd rather just get a character-driven
narrative honestly more than anything else and
then let some commentary speak via through that
which is how I think commentary generally should
be ex it's called subtext yeah exactly because
there's a lot of textual talk in here yeah whereas
uh here I'm like the concert doesn't really do
anything that new for The Hunger Games world uh
not really like everything that they touch on
with uh oppression classism and War all that
people as animals and you yeah like prisoners the
the way they've explor all these Earth yeah we've
seen all that and and honestly that's the thing
with Francis Lawrence who I feel like is on the
unlike unlike David Yates because David okay for
those who don't know David Yates made Order of
Phoenix I think that was his first one and then
he just made every Harry Potter fantastic Beast
he didn't take a break to do anything else yeah
whereas Francis Lawrence has at least done stuff
since the last Hunger Games movie and and then
this one right but at the same time it is like I
feel like we kind of needed a fresh director to I
do feel like because the first two acts while not
bad I don't think they're bad I don't feel like
they're anywhere near as interesting as the last
act because there is a certain element of kind of
going by the numbers while they do some different
things even like the new stuff that they're
introducing kind of feels like yeah this is
about the Beats you expect them to hit with the
origin of snow in this early Hunger Games story
it it does feel a little bit like in terms of
outlining and and that's where the richness
would come in with just stronger scene work or
or really be like even not being like I don't
even really care about that stuff being like
the outline being a little bit what I expected
it's but the scenes themselves really shine and
and so that's where predictability versus uh you
know actual storytelling you and and to me I'm
like yeah it was kind of weaving in and out uh
for me of being really connected whereas like the
third part three of of this post The Hunger Games
is when I felt like Francis Lawrence finally like
lit up yeah I was like okay I get to bring some of
that stuff I've probably been raking in from
more recent experiences and apply it to this
yeah I got to do something different cuz to the
movie's credit one of the best things about and
and and I keep forgetting it's actually based on a
this one's based on a book you're forgetting that
but to the story of it is there's been a lot of
origin Tales of people that just seem unnecessary
or I I don't even like that word necessary you
know when people say that this fil is necessary
I don't really like that word necessary um that
the the origins feel so predictable the origins
feel like well we know we're going to go here
we know is going to happen we know and and the
only thing we really that was a obvious is that
he's got to end up a bad guy by the end and B um
it probably something to do with the Heartbreak
here that he experienced with this but the way
that unfolds while some stuff you can sort of
telegraph like a like several minutes before
it happens for the most part I really was like
I don't know how he's going to end up to being
the snow or or at least end up on the path of
being the snow that we know him to be by the
time he becomes Donald southernland yeah and I
thought that was a strength that kept me watching
because I was because I could not see it really
I'm like I don't really know and by the time we
got there it actually really clicked for me it I
thought it was great on how they did it cuz they
took Avenues primarily in the part three act they
took Avenues and directions that kind of let plot
points unfold in ways that don't actually feel
cliche and I don't think they are cliche they
took different directions that I thought were
actually really unexpected of why he does what
he does or how he lands where he lands where he
does come to the lesson of the world is not the
Hunger Games are merely a mirror you know and I
thought that was kind of powerful I thought that
was great it's a distillation of everything that's
going on all over this place because we isolate
the Hunger Games but they are a reflection of us
in a in a way right and so I actually really like
the third act really bumped this up a lot for me
whereas the first two Acts were I I'm I'm picking
and choosing what I really like well the first two
acts of that Blockbuster thing that happens where
you have like a bunch of talent and not enough
you know time to really let that spread out yeah
and and Ian even the hunger game itself was like
just yeah it's a little It's Kind honestly it's
this a weird word to say a part of it feels like
it's kind of cute to me of oh yeah it's like an
older version oh yeah look at that it's the older
version that's how a lot of it was sort of reading
yeah instead of really having the suspense and
stakes and the Menace people finally the most
violent [__] that happens is someone people
fall you know like and I thought oh we're in a
more like barbaric setting where usually we're in
this like giant landscape yeah and I and and and
I and I thought it actually completely didn't have
the no I want to say completely it was void of the
grit that the other ones had even especially the
first movie's grit like the first movie I remember
not knowing what I was going to go watch and sure
there might have been like the shock Val of it of
someone who had no idea what the Hunger Games was
about and be like these kids are married like but
see but it was still captured in a way that
I remember being like this is really violent
these are like kid like the way it was being sh
even pg3 Humanity of it all yeah yeah like bord
personally it borders on R and and and and this
I thought really should have towed the line and
it The Hunger Games themselves were like yeah fine
that's that's the thing about so much of the first
two chapters of this and why I do honestly think
that if any of these should have been split into
two this would be a good candidate because that's
the thing is I yeah it's like I think it's a neat
idea of doing like okay so it's like the 10th one
we've done a couple of these enough to know that
it's not going to be like completely makeshift but
yeah it's not what you are used to in the future
that's a cool Prospect because you can play up
the humor like with the drones but I feel like
the half that they are missing is the way which
that's totally more barbaric or it would lead
to a games that is a lot more feral and Scrappy
and like that there are glimpses of that like the
weapons do like hearken back to like old Gladiator
stuff and you know it's not super Hightech but I
feel like surface though it it it is yeah and and
so you have these cartoon you know all the other
competitors fell into their cartoon you know
archetypes and you have like a literal puppy
killing with the one girl with the tuberculosis
and the one guy over here who's just like you
know The Chosen hero and everyone in between the
problem with the runtime is that you you're now
short in like the other two movies that's most of
the runtime is the it's the game and here you're
like we got to condense that runtime because yeah
see again not I guess I'm just gonna Embrace that
these are the ideas the movie is giving me not to
like totally rewrite but I feel like it's good to
keep it in Snow's perspective I I like what
they tried to do with The Hunger Games I feel
like you could have done a lot with the tension
like you could show her perspective in the games
to a greater emotional degree and and ride off
the simultaneous nature of the fact that he's
in one place around the establishment watching her
and can only do so much to help and she's you know
literally stranded in Lord of the Flies right now
so like there's so much Mutual tension and cutting
back and forth and stuff that you could do in the
moment to really make that gripping and and again
like one thing those old Hunger Games movies did
do was at least take some time to like okay we're
meeting all the other contestants in they get
their intros in front of the city but then we
do like the behind the scenes like oh this is
what they're really like and this is you know
who I'm up against and who might be an ally and
you get to wonder about all these things a little
whereas this is moving so quickly that it it just
doesn't give you time for mystery or wondering
much of anything that isn't clearly going to be
end of the movie Reveal stuff and that's where I
think to your point of where some of the stuff of
because we're focused on snow Snow's perspective
not um uh Lucy's perspective where Lucy gray
whereas the movies are focused on Katniss's
perspective who is in The Hunger Games yeah so
you you're more connected to it you're you're
more connected to the entire thing and so I think
the idea was to kind of flip perspective but it
was trying to have its cake and E to two a little
bit you know and and I think that's where some of
it and because of the fact that it's this number
installment movie the only people who are going
to watch I most people who are going to watch
this this is going to be the fourth Hunger Games
movie they're watching no the fifth this is GNA
be the fifth Hunger Games movie because there's
the MJ's two parts right yeah yeah this will be
the fifth Hunger Game movie you're watching and
not uh their first one so you naturally well yeah
know it does and that's the thing is there is an
awaren too so yeah cuz yeah I think too it's like
it rushes pretty quickly past them their initial
distrust and the spirit they suggest upon their
first meeting just doesn't seem like someone who
would warm up to him that fast so I feel like they
needed to earn moments like that and yeah you can
do a lot of things still within his perspective
but that develop that that's what made him uh
that's what made me like question her but back to
her I mean I think that her Rachel zler again and
I feel like that it's become like this hot Buton
keyw word to talk about her um I don't really
care I mean I I thought she was the absolute
standout in this movie I came in here to watch
the origin of The Hunger Games and the origin of
our favorite dictator and Rachel zler I I forgot
she was in it till a moment before they showed
her I was like oh yeah Rachel zler is in this
movie I was not expecting her character to be such
a standout her the songs that they I don't know if
they wrote those songs I don't know if they're
uh at um covers I don't know what regardless I
thought they helped serve the narrative and help
develop her character and her voice and the mood
how it creates an atmosphere around her and it's
something that I think could have really failed
at how they executed it to be in here is just
something that feels completely cheesy and silly
uh yet you can see how that is also the start and
origin of uh of something theatrical to endear you
to the audience in terms of like in The Hunger
Games world of how they do that the theatrics
to make them a little bit more performers who are
tributes the tributes make them more performers
and and uh but but her performance overall like I
was most concerned about her like I didn't she was
the only one where I was like oo I I don't want
her to die and the stakes are really real for for
you cuz you're in district 12 at the moment and
you're also you know part of a traveling group of
people who seems to be on the fringes of society
anyway and and I like that they use the music like
the music does I think a good amount to bridge
some of the gaps because music does just speak in
ways that words don't always and and a lot of the
lyrics kind of are directly about situations that
happen but I feel like you know the emotional
rousing that music can provide is put to good
effect here and I like that it also plays into the
tradition of like yeah in rebellions music plays a
big part both for morale and for this sending of
messages and other things like that and so like
that's a nice astute detail to put in there that's
perfectly in line to do what often happens in in
earlier Hunger Games installments where it's
like okay this is technically a rebellion but
you can warp it into being part of the show too
you know the the one is part part of the Matrix
you know yeah uh and so yeah like that was like a
cool thread that they didn't have to commit to to
the degree that they did I thought that was like
a nice artistic surprise they put on this it was
a really nice artistic surprise and I like The
Descent of snow where he normally in these movies
where someone becomes a monster you just watched
them become less human and more cold by the end
and I thought the choice to actually do do kind of
an inverse where he actually seems more detached
honestly in the beginning to in the be in the very
very beginning of the movie he seems a little bit
more detached and I get it his family was once of
prominence and he's putting on sort of this like
posturing Act of Elegance that even Peter Dinklage
calls him out on yeah and then so then you're
slowly getting to see like oh he's actually but
some of his earlier on scenes I didn't really I
feel like he was cast for what he did in the later
half sure and not so much what he did in the first
half and in that first half um yeah cuz I I think
his real strengths were in that last half and in
that first half of the movie you you are watching
as he's becoming more human right from falling in
love to the fear and paranoia even when he starts
doing villainous Deeds or corrupted Deeds that are
out of just selfish gain it where he's playing his
own Real World Hunger Games like as someone who
was a mentoring he playing Real World Hunger Games
he actually feels like he's becoming more and more
human as he becomes quote quot unquote a monster
I guess you know and I and I thought that was
actually a nice way of doing an origin for like
oh look at him he's a good guy and we're going to
watch him become bad and they did it in a way that
was different it didn't feel like he completely
became sometimes in origin movies they they really
Telegraph very early on that this is who they like
oh you're going to see them become bad and is
Right streak was always in them yeah yeah they do
that or they uh I don't know there's there's all
other kinds of versions of cliches and I haven't
quite seen it done this way like when he's in the
woods trying to shoot her he still feels like a
very multi-layered human in that moment who is
experiencing paranoia heartbreak fear of loss SW
like I thought he embodied the multiple layers and
he felt that's what I'm trying to say I felt like
he actually became multi-layered and multifaceted
um at the as the movie went and by especially by
the end and that's why I feel like he's more Human
by The End even though he's more cold whereas in
the beginning I didn't really feel the multiple
layers of this character and it took me a while to
get actually interested in who snow this version
of snow it it really took me some time like Rachel
zler was kind of right off the bat whereas um
her uh him took me some time and then the other
performers too of course like Peter Dinklage was
you know Peter D was kind of doing something we
were familiar with Peter Dinklage doing but it
was still like he still committ he still Peter
nckl he's still great yeah he's still great he's
still doing the performance and Jason schwarzman
as just call him young Stanley Tui always forget
that character's name lucky flickerman or whatever
I liked how you know the comparison differen is
Stanley Tucci is is very much he's a superstar
you know um he's Regis filbin and then this is
Young Regis filbin you know gu's working his way
up yeah he's holding the show together but he's
also singing for his dinner yeah yeah totally I
thought J Sportsman was excellent and yeah think
performances costumes all look great and the
aesthetic of making it like retro sci-fi where
it feels like how the 50s and 60s imagine what
the future would look like uh so I thought that
was really cool and and yeah the third act to me
was um that that's when I felt this movie really
sang a lot and and had the most amount of actual
tension to hold on to and and concern and worry
and I like that you don't find out what really
happened with her you keep it a mystery with Lucy
G even as The singing's Happening the wood just a
thing that the birds are recalling above him is
this just an echo in his mind did she really you
know yeah did she even really exist The Hunger
Games head yeah but like no like like I guess
that's the last thought that I kind of have is is
is is yeah I think the the most important thing
this movie had to do for itself given what it's
set out to do is sell the character journey of
Cory elanus snow and I thought the most graceful
thing about it was the way they did sort of weave
in and out of moral gray areas and you can see
him in multiple in in almost in you know the
same scene at times you know like swaying more
toward a benevolent side swaying more toward the
machinations of the capital you know right right
you know for for as kind of straightforward or as
surface level as certain things were it felt like
that part of the story they really always managed
like I love that thing with Peter Dinklage because
yeah you think he's just being a Snape about it
because like I knew your dad back in the day
Potter like you know I'm going to stick it to
you whereas you know you come back around and
it's like oh this guy and that's at a point in
the story where Coro is sort of seemingly flirting
with more of a humanist perspect or is being drawn
more toward a humanist perspective so that gives
you more cause to suspect that uh the the um what
high bottom or whatever his name is like is a bad
guy and then later on oh you find out he's helping
out the rebels and he did this because he thinks
you're just like your dad even though you've like
tried not to be throughout this movie but now
you're still being set down that path you know
and it's and I think we needed some depiction
of the dad that would have been nice yeah cuz
there was all this emphasis on him and I was and I
didn't really if they still kept it so vague just
something we don't like for me you don't even need
to see his face necessarily but like show a window
into the moments where he did have time with his
dad to form any association cuz we first meet him
as like a kid out in the snow like getting taken
in from you know squalor so like where was how old
was he when he knew his dad like all there's
questions there I think what I never really
latched on to with the movie is why snow cares to
get this [Music] far cuz he's the special and his
dad created The Hunger Games but you know like at
the very beginning like of course I'm not going to
relate with this there's got to be something there
to relate with the motivation like I think they're
trying to tell me that all this stuff with this
and his grandma he really loves them so he wants
to take care of them is what the movie's I think
trying to tell me yeah will never be evicted again
but that wasn't I don't know I like this specific
thing you going to lead this place this specific
thing yeah he was aspiring to at the very jump
of this movie and why are you so inspired with
ways to make the games that much better cuz this
whole thing is predicated on like oh he's got this
crazy ass plan for how to make the games great
and I feel like we glossed over that cuz I think
there was something there in the text about
um and maybe I missed it but feel like I paid
attention to everything the the because it seems
like the family was once respected yeah and once
of regality in some regard and then now they're
not and he wants to reclaim that good name I think
maybe but he also seems very detached to cult but
it also seems like everyone who finds out who his
dad is other than Peter Dinklage was like your dad
was an all right guy you know yeah man he gave us
this so I don't know I mean but he didn't know
that right not until later I don't I thought it
seemed like he didn't know his dad gave him till
the very end yeah seems like uh he took somehow
for some reason that it's been lost yeah not even
orever or maybe just he was never in a position to
have it revealed to him or something like that
but even such yeah it's like that's right it's
cuz the hunger gam hadn't even happened yet cuz
we started off 3 years before he gets taken in
yeah 3 years before when they're like little kids
and then and then so sometime I I guess what is
it he's taken in by the guy who would eventually
create the Hunger Games that like that part kind
of confused because we don't really ever see him
and we see Grandma or whoever that is uh but yeah
and then we cut to 10 years later or whatever
yeah because the movie starts off three years
before the first Hunger Games yeah right it said
the first Hunger Games yeah um and then I guess
they had that conversation through a few years
before the first Hunger Games like like that's
the thing is yeah like it would have been even if
this is not about the first Hunger Games it would
have been nice to check in with the first Hunger
Games like I feel like that would kind of almost
be important for how close the part of the point
is like we've only been doing this for a little
while and you know they're flailing out here we
got to figure out a way to really beef this up and
and get everyone on board and I think that would
have been I think it's be a really challenging
it's like the first the movie The of The Purge
franchise and there's there there are correlations
I think you can draw parallels in terms of
the story and what they're talking about and
what they're doing between what the Hunger Game
stories are about and what the purge movies are
about even though they're very different movies
there's a lot of similarities at the same time AB
um in terms of some contextual things and and I
think that would have made for in terms of like
a a thematic piece the a more interesting thematic
piece yeah because you would see how people like
were reacting to when this was first announced
and when they were going to do it and then how
the response went over when it went when when it
uh when it does go down yeah and then the unknown
of how how this is supposed to work and figure
it out see that's the thing is you could have a
Hunger Games again and and again do you know the
part of any you know continuing franchise where
we do the thing from the first time again but you
can give it a whole new you know uh veneer and a
whole new kind of you know set of circumstances
that could make it fresh and interesting in a
more rudimentary and rough kind of way and tap
into you know like the signature aspect of like
what Drew people to this franchise in many ways
like yeah some some pretty straightforward but
you know very invested commentary on society in
various ways and even this like it flirts at the
end with they they either reject Society leave
and go someplace else or they try to climb to
the top and and fix it and all that and like yeah
things were so bad and these wars happened and we
split up all these districts and stuff and it was
so bad we had to create this game right to to make
an example but also just like Sate people's anger
and keep people complacent and whatever else and
like and yeah like it it is odd to me not to
at least touch on that like I feel like maybe
they're just keeping that Ace up their sleeve so
if they you know want to in another five or six
years or if this Trilogy doesn't work they can go
first Hunger Games let's get cycle three going um
but it I don't know I feel like again for drawing
it so close to that and doing some of that I feel
like you could have just made that stuff even more
Rich by at least touching on the first games well
uh overall n you know I'd probably give this movie
uh like guess there's a lot of things I really
liked about it though man like whenever Rachel
zler was on screen and I really did find a lot
of suspense in the last hour of this film yeah
and uh and I'm glad they put it there like you
know again in the math I I would rather be left
off on an interesting note oh yeah rush through
act three it feels grounded and gritty and it
feels like the real world allegories are even
more present and you put snow in a position where
there are Stakes where you like you start to semi
forget like oh yeah you're supposed to somehow
get back to the capital and be he's stripped
down I think that's another thing that helps with
the character he's stripped down he's vulnerable
he's taken away from everything and he's traversed
all levels of this society and he's been in favor
he's been out of favor and and in that last
half you're able to kind of live I think one
thing doing this perspective allows you to do
is live in the banality of the daytoday of this
[__] which the third act really does do cuz he's
he's a stormtrooper the other thing I really liked
that I completely forgot to touch on was that you
actually get a sense of community from District
12 where in in this like movie that feels is
dystopian future you you normally don't get
something that feels joyous celebratory in any way
and you get that there when they are and that was
one of the elements of the musical side where that
connection when they are singing and dancing and
and uh and Lucy Grace performing I'm like oh yeah
there's a real there is a community here yeah and
you are connected and endeared to that at least
I was and I don't that's something I don't feel
the other Hunger Games mov you know just felt like
they were everyone's broken throwing bread in the
mud you know dreary and dirty all the time which
is part of that life but also yeah show contr yeah
and and I thought that like finding having that
kind of community with the with with the southern
flare to it was actually pretty cool and also
you know and and to get Rachel zegler who I I
don't think she's Caucasian uh she something she's
like Latina or something I don't know what she is
but she's obviously she's not Caucasian and to to
see someone who who embodies such a Southern bell
kind of vibe who is not Caucasian I thought was
actually kind of was like different and refreshing
and it balances things out cuz she is singing a
lot of like very bluesy spirituals which I think
would be kind of extra tacky if it was just like
a white girl yeah and I think some people might be
like what the hell uh you know but I'm like all
all that has to happen is someone just grows up
around that you the voice of the cad it's matters
and the culture you know it's like when you see
like I don't know a Japanese guy who grows up in
Australia he has an Australian accent yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly this is this is clearly a place
in which people have been all Just jumed Around by
War in class and now you know wherever you wind
up especially her is like a nomad you know like
wherever you wind up is sort of whatever culture
you're going to pick up like I know we see that
in life all the time uh but in movies and shows
you really don't you know there's a uniformity
that that often happens whereas here I thought
that yeah they they they managed to make the
district feel alive and feel like yeah despite you
know the thing that all like many places in Squad
there still can be senses of community and ways
to find joy and respit whilst also never kind of
being unaware of the fact that you're always under
the boot th% and yeah you can feel yeah it's like
I I liked like I liked getting those bits where
you do at least just have sort of like life's
happening and people are breaking out in song and
they're dancing and you really kind of feel like
what a day in the life is like over here you know
and what we're fighting for yeah I can't help but
think like even though I like the third act a lot
the that there are I can't help but at times be
like I really feel like half hour would have added
this in and maybe it's there in the book but even
even with his friend that that's where the part
I I forget his name surgey oh so Soju something
like that the the the the the best friendship
there could have been a heartbreaking thing if
at all he did feel compelled to help him out if he
did think like the if there was a debate with with
them truly of potentially helping out the rebels
and stuff yeah and that way that creates a real
conflict you see him actually making a choice
that and even would drive home that desent that
character art that he has more when he does go
like no he's shutting the [__] down he's not
going to help you know yeah and giving that car
again it's that breathing room thing of like man
just a couple more scenes showing these guys in
a joyous moment and in a moment where you can see
how his buddy is is rubbing off on him because he
they establish that he's his only friend you're
the only guy who sticks up for this dude who
clearly has a sympathetic side for the plees
out there you know and he speaks to his humanity
and I think you you said something early on about
certain scenes feeling kind of soap opera esque
because the emotion has to be high because it's
the important scenes that we're cutting to uh but
I feel like especially with a character like that
like they managed to get a good amount of the
tragedy but I feel like some of it some of the
real contrast and the real weight of it is a
bit garbled like they kind of make they kind
of streamline it in a way where you're like
yeah he's gonna betray him whereas like you
want to feel like uh will this be less of a direct
betrayal and more of like a choice made under one
pretense only to be like oh God no what did I do
you know there could have been more debate there
and there could have been again just a a greater
detailing of that kind of swaying of corus's Soul
between two states and two ideologies you know
yeah and I think in a book when you're reading a
bunch of additional texts yeah but in a movie you
you got to do a little more creative work to do
some scene work you do some sew work a little more
to drive home the plot and cuz cuz he especially
uh uh sojourn whatever his name is is very much
a a themes character I'm here for the to bring
the themes in the text of the them and to present
those to you cor snow and I'm like cool good like
that's you need that and I like that you know
they have a whole argument kind of their whole
ideology is like do we do direct action or do we
play the long game and and you know what are our
motivations really and yeah it's like that stuff
could have felt a lot more lived in and you could
have felt a little less you know the the a little
less of that puppy killing feeling when it really
does come down you know on on his head th% and
the weight of that broken promise I'll protect
you overall 7.5 for me John yeah yeah 7.2 all
right give it a s Point all right either way I
think we were both like pleasantly surprised and
like the the good stuff was better than expected
and the stuff that doesn't work could have worked
stuff I did not show up for all were the things
that I thought were the best parts great surpr
great surise all the stuff I did not care about
before end I was like oh damn this is actually the
most interesting well of all the people like just
bound to a franchise well done Francis Lawrence
and Company yeah but I think you should move on
uh I think all these dudes need to move on I think
you should all righty guys leave your thoughts
down below what you thought Hunger Games ballot of
song birds and snakes and and uh hey before we go
let's end this with a p Ana Oliva Ana it is 2024
oh and I was thinking about it in the year of Co
oh which you know it's still very much real but in
still out there but in the year when you know the
pandemic was at its Heights out here in the states
I remember we would do live streams and you were
contributing boatloads of cash you were like ready
to go broke yeah and I just feel like you don't
really do that anymore yeah it's been a long time
and part of me is wondering why we should still be
shouting you out I mean yeah you you pledge for
this but what is that I mean that's just to get
in the door you know that's just the cover chart
but now we have an we have an expectation bar of
what to receive from your end and the bar only
ever rides it's really limits the passion behind
the shout outs for when we're not financially
incentivized for the bonus that it could lead
to a more stimulating shout out comes from more
stimulating stimulus package and I'm not dropping
a hint here I'm not saying what you should do
there are a could and would scenario here that
could be happening and ought to mandatory but
hey hey I'm no gaslighter all right I didn't
hear nothing G I'm no manipulator around here so I
I can't tell you what to do with your funds no no
no never but I'm just saying it's a new year it's
just friendly advice you know and um the pandemic
height was a while ago and we went through all the
2023 well you risked your life out there and now
we're in 2024 I'm just hoping that well in 2023
where you like saving up stock here to dish out
monthly cuz she knew it was going to come back and
then she would start showering us again to protect
us from the all the antigens outside I'm not I'm
not not suggesting just you know just implying
just uh throwing a thought just spitball in here
right just spitball in here go with me on this
that's your you do what you want to do yeah you
know you're a independent woman do what you want
yeah and the great thing is so often your interest
and needs align perfectly with ours so that makes
us Independent Women too just saying give us
give us a lot more give us some money give us
a lot more get pledge more find the streamlabs
link go there and I'm also offline Super Chat
saying to let me be clear that if you do end up
sending us a lot more money due to this shout out
we are going to be filled with obnoxious amounts
of guilt so please don't do it not actually the
disclaimer this is not a serious shout out
normally I would really just stick to the
B but we can put a long zoom on it so clear that
this is a joke we know you pretty well and I'm I
feel like this joke could really go badly and you
would be like oh [__] I better send them please
don't just that you have been here for as long
as you have and have been as lovely for as long
as the greatest gift please don't do it so yeah
we don't need it for you've been amazing and yep
let's get through a tough period on the channel
so thank you and I'll never forget that and we've
of course gotten to know you as a actual human
being and person and you've been wonderful gym so
I hope in 2024 uh that you are able to use money
to invest so that way you could just have pure
Financial Freedom stocks and also I hope you get
married this year hope you find a guy marry him
he better worst things you can do with your money
worst things you could do with your money [Music]